we are doing things with overwatch 2
that would be difficult to do without
the context of it being a sequel we are
reworking the pvp experience for
overwatch we're shifting from a 6v6 team
format to a 5v5 team format it's
removing one of the tanks from the
lineup we're also introducing role
passives for every hero we are reworking
and modifying a lot of the heroes in the
game we're removing crowd control
abilities from the game and so we're
able to keep all of that going forward
but at the same time overwatch 2 it does
feel like something fresh and something
new and i think it's easier to do
something like that in the context of a
sequel
[Music]
yeah this is a
really exciting time for the team um
overwatch launched
six years ago in 2016 and we've released
updates to the game but this october
when we release overwatch 2 it will be
the largest update we've ever released
for overwatch there'll be
new heroes new maps new game modes a
totally reworked pvp system and for us
to have been working on this for so long
over the course of years
without really being able to show it to
the public
this is a moment that the team is now
being able to focus on and get really
really excited about so to have the game
out in the public and to have an actual
launch date for the game
is really thrilling for us
[Music]
yeah we have a few values that we keep
in mind as we develop overwatch too it's
one of the things that um
that sort of caused the shift to free to
play is that we want to keep our
community together as as much as we can
and so rather than releasing another box
that players would have to buy in order
to opt into the experience we'd rather
open the game to as a broad of a
population as possible so overwatch it's
a universe that welcomes everyone you
know and we want people to be able to
play with as many of their friends as
they want to it's overwatch is a game of
teamwork and cooperation and strategy
and and we feel like it's played best in
a social setting or or with your friends
and so removing that barrier to entry
at the price as a barrier to entry is
hopefully a way for you to be able to
play with more of your friends and have
a better experience with the game
[Music]
we are doing things with overwatch 2
that would be difficult to do without
the context of it being a sequel we are
reworking the pvp experience for
overwatch we're shifting from a 6v6 team
format to a 5v5 team format it's
removing one of the tanks from the
lineup we're also introducing role
passives for every hero we are reworking
and modifying a lot of the heroes in the
game we're removing crowd control
abilities from the game and so i think
that overwatch has a certain magic to it
when you play it there's this mojo it
just it just feels great to play it
and we're able to keep all of that going
forward but at the same time overwatch 2
it does feel like something
fresh and something new and i think it's
easier to do something like that in the
context of a sequel on top of that
this is the largest update we've ever
released for the game
there are a lot of new things coming out
in october with new heroes and new maps
we have a new competitive system coming
out and there's so much more to come so
by going free to play with overwatch we
are not just giving people a different
way of interacting with the game the
development team itself
is thinking about the way we create and
release content in a totally new way the
amount of content it takes to run a
free-to-play live service game is orders
of magnitude more than what it takes to
run something that you put into a box
and sell it so the whole overwatch team
it's totally
like restructured and grown it's over
three times the size it was when we
launched the original game and it's
structured in such a way that we can
simultaneously work on things for the
launch and the rest of this year but
next year as well and and i think this
is this is also a shift in the way we
think about releasing big pieces of the
game so rather than just developing
things and holding them and then
combining them to put into a box we're
now committed to releasing them when
they're ready and doing that for the
long term the overwatch team we're we're
still working on all of the parts
all of the pve parts of overwatch too
that we've always envisioned for it but
now rather than releasing them in a box
we're going to be releasing them as part
of our seasonal cadence i know that
there's a lot here but really this is a
demarcation point for overwatch where
the way we create and release content is
different and even the way we think
about and run the game is different so
in my opinion this justifies putting the
two after overwatch
[Music]
going free to play is a pretty big
change
for a team and for a game the last thing
we want to do is put all of our
resources into developing this release
for october 4th and then have everybody
on the team burn out have everybody want
to take a vacation october is the start
of overwatch too it's the beginning of a
new era for the game and it really just
marks the moment where we need to start
releasing more and more content for
players and so we have to structure a
team that can work on um a lot of
different pieces of content at the same
time a lot of different seasons and it's
not just cosmetic content but it's
heroes it's maps it's game modes it's
new features and systems it's new events
for the game and so to be able to do all
of that for multiple seasons all at the
same time
is a it's a pretty massive shift for us
to to be able to actually hit that
[Music]
one of the big changes that were that
we're making to overwatch and one of the
big changes that the team has really
embraced is that we really want to bring
players along on this journey with us so
we want to be more transparent about
we're doing what we're doing and we want
to give greater detail of what our plans
are for the future we are we're
releasing a road map
that goes over the first few seasons
specifically but also in general
roughly the first year of what we're
going to be releasing for overwatch we
we never did something like that but
also um when when you have a game that
is kind of your main game you know like
this is the thing i'm going to go home
and i'm going to play overwatch tonight
you become invested in in something like
that and it it's more than just
what can i play right now you start
kind of looking to the future for
something like that it becomes more a
part of your life and i think that
having information about where something
that important to people is going is
really important so the overwatch team
is is embracing that as as a new value
for us
[Music]
loot boxes they've always been a part of
overwatch one but as the game has grown
and especially as we go into
a free-to-play version of the game where
we're adding more and more cosmetics it
becomes a lot harder to earn what you
want with a loot box system and so um by
losing those and moving over to a shop
for overwatch too it gives players the
actual agency and the choice to go after
what it is they want to have in the game
with the amount of heroes that we have
in the game
and the amount of content that we're
developing for all of them it can be a
really exciting thing now to to say like
oh this is the hero that i like to play
and i see all of this stuff that's
that's available to me and then you can
choose whether you want to engage with
it or not
[Music]
i think that um going forward that's
really the the place that our battle
pass is going to take battle passes
typically have a track where there's
progression through it and so as you
play more of the game you'll move
through the battle pass and it'll it'll
kind of hit a lot of the same spots that
that our our previous progression system
did
[Music]
so with mythic skins we've taken
all of that everything that we're doing
to our legendary skins and we're
plussing it we're taking it over the top
our mythic skins are customizable you
can change different different like
various parts of the skin and different
looks for it so for season one
we're we're premiering with our genji
mythic skin
he has different tattoos that you can
swap on and off different different
colors he has different weapons that you
can equip for him
and i think the coolest part about him
is he's got like this really cool mask
covering his face and when you um go
into his ultimate when you activate his
ultimate the mask opens up and there's
all these cool vfx in there and so it's
just something um that i think when
players see it they'll kind of recognize
that it's a whole tier above what our
legendary skins are and i hope that they
really really love it
[Music]
right now we're planning on having a new
mythic skin debut every season in the
game
[Music]
so junker queen is our latest hero she's
a tank um and we're going to debut her
as part of the next beta so she has some
new mechanics that we don't have in
overwatch yet i think that we're really
excited for she utilizes a mechanic
called bleed
and when she does certain types of
damage to characters she receives
that same amount um as overhealth to her
and there's lots of different ways for
her to do it she fights with an axe a
dagger and she uses this like
electromagnetic gauntlet to control some
of this so when she throws her dagger
out she can then reactivate the ability
and pull it back
and it will pull it will like
pierce everybody that's in the way of it
so you can hit somebody on the way out
and pull it back and do damage to them
again or sometimes you can purposefully
miss
and put it behind a team and then pull
it back through them um hitting each one
of them applying a bleed to each one of
them and taking all of that as
overhealth
also when she swings her axe when she
cleaves with it
she can take all of that damage and
apply a bleed and get that as overhealth
as well so if she's playing right and
hitting people frequently she's able to
be really tanky and kind of just stay up
in front of people and on top of that
she has a buff where she shouts
and she gives basically a haste
as well as over health to to herself as
well as all of her allies and so she's
one of these tanks that she's not long
range but when she's in the thick of
things and when she's hitting people
she's really really hard to take down
[Music]
developing content for a live service
game a free-to-play live service game is
a pretty major undertaking i understand
that there can be some doubt from the
community as to whether or not
the team is up to this task
we have really
grown and really reorganized this team
all with the singular focus of being
able to create as much content as we can
and to put it out on a consistent and
frequent seasonal basis
we have
multiple heroes multiple post-release
heroes in development as we speak one of
them is
already almost ready to go and so i feel
like for the foreseeable future this is
a cadence that we can hit we wouldn't
put something
into a public-facing roadmap if we
didn't have a pretty high degree of
confidence that we would be able to
actually hit the dates that that that we
were promising to the public
[Music]
it's really interesting to talk about
the future of overwatch when there's a
bunch of other heroes in the game
and to figure out how the game will
actually play when it's like that
and i think we can theorycraft some of
that it's really difficult to get that
right from the from the beginning i
think
what i'm excited about and what some of
the team is excited about is by
introducing new heroes to the game we
are introducing change to the game um
and it's it's a new value of ours that
we we don't just want this release to
feel fresh we don't just want the launch
of overwatch 2 to feel like it's
something different we kind of always
want it to feel like it's growing and
evolving and changing and if you think
back to the history of overwatch as we
introduced different heroes to the
roster most of the time those would all
introduce either new mechanics or a new
meta there there wasn't as big of a need
to do all of the balance changes um that
um it feels like um the community has
been calling for over the past year when
we haven't had things like new heroes
added to the game
and so yes i think that there are going
to be changes but those changes are
actually a positive thing for the game
and there's something that we're looking
forward to
[Music]
oh yes you're asking for
for like deep dark secrets of overwatch
development um yeah so we have a we have
a pretty good idea of um most of the
content and features that are coming out
um for for almost the whole first year
of overwatch too and i think they'll
probably be more than what we have on
the roadmap sometimes it's just hard to
predict everything that you're going to
be able to get in and also everything
that the game might need based off of
the way players in the community reacts
to it one of the really exciting things
about going free to play is just the
change in the way we're thinking about
releasing big pieces of the game so we
might not know
what hero we're releasing two years from
now
but we do have an idea of some of the
really big things that we have been
working on that will make their way
into seasonal releases and one of those
is the pve experience that we've always
envisioned to be a part of overwatch too
[Music]
yeah one of the one of the like really
encouraging pieces of feedback that we
got from the beta was not only that the
game felt fresh and different was that
there was a lot of positivity
surrounding 5e5 and a lot of times when
you just announce that you're doing
something different especially when it's
like a fundamental change to a game and
you announce that without people being
able to play it there can be a lot of
skepticism surrounding it um and you get
it in a lot of different formats so it
can be something like hey i i don't
think that having one tank on the field
is going to be as fun there's gonna
there's support aren't gonna have people
peel for them or there's gonna be too
much pressure on one tank and another um
criticism that you could get sometimes
is hey i have a team of six people that
i play with all the time how are we
going to manage something like that
going forward and i think that at least
on the first two fronts and a lot of the
other gameplay concerns
it felt like most people were really
positive on the gameplay changes that
that we were introducing on the the the
side where people have a group of six
people playing right now we don't have a
great answer for it um i i can't i can't
say that that um that there is going to
be a 6v6 mode for those people there are
things that we're talking about
internally that we're really excited
about but i don't think that they're
going to make launch and one of those
things is is adding support for group
sizes larger than five where people will
be able to seamlessly spectate and then
drop in and out so you could at least
have a group of friends that can all
hang out and play overwatch together
even if they're not all playing the same
game at the same time
[Music]
when we
initially announced overwatch 2
we presented a vision of a pvp game that
um
had a big pve component to it at the
same time and as we developed that game
what it meant was that the pvp side of
the game was coupled or was joined with
the pve side of the game and so the
release of any pvp content was now being
gated by the amount of time it took for
us to to build the pve side of the game
and as that took longer it meant that
there was less focus going in to the
live side of the game um and
this i feel like this went against one
of the core values that the overwatch
team has always had which is to be able
to deliver content regularly for our
players and so the longer that went i
think we realized that
we had to change something
and so i understand that that there was
a vision of what overwatch 2 was but we
are changing that and the reason that we
are changing that is because we want to
be able to get content to our players as
soon as we possibly can we think that
that is the right thing to do for our
community we think it's the right thing
to do for the game it's the right thing
to do for all of our players and so that
was the initial impetus of what caused
us to to completely
change our strategy
[Music]
i love the the cinematics the um that
blizzard makes um i'm a fan of them i've
cried during every single overwatch
animated short i don't know if it's me
or if it's the movie but it just has
like this kind of powerful effect on me
anytime we release new content to the
game we typically try to make um a
different cinematic for it all of our
heroes have an origin story for them and
then when we're able to we try to
highlight a lot of that with our bigger
pieces the big animated shorts that we
do over the past few years as we had
been focusing on overwatch 2 we released
less content to the game but now that we
are moving into this new era of
overwatch where it's free to play and
there it will be a constant stream of
new content coming out
a lot of it will be new heroes we need
new pieces to reinforce all of that so
we'll be releasing new origin stories we
have several animated shorts that we're
working on that we cannot wait to share
with players and yes i cry during all of
those too
and so i think um in this like this new
model of the game you will players will
be able to expect more storytelling than
they've had before
[Music]
so in
the next beta overwatch will debut a new
pvp map it takes place in rio and it's
called perisso
the map is one of our hybrid types so it
means that
attackers will need to capture an
objective and then from there they will
escort a payload through the rest of the
map and there's a lot of really
interesting things about the map
just because it takes place in rio it
has this like amazing coastal scene to
it
attackers come out of the spawn room and
there's this massive beach in front of
them and all of the buildings are so
incredibly colorful there and even
there's this set of stairs like halfway
through the map and every tile on the
stairs
is a different color and so this map is
like it's incredibly vibrant and it's
it's really lively and i think it it
really expresses um that that part of
the world um and the other really
exciting thing about rio is um this is
the home of lucio so the last third of
the map actually takes place in lucio's
club
and you get to move through the space as
you're pushing the payload through there
the defenders are actually spawning in
lucio's home and so you get a look at
where he lives at his own personal
mixing booth in there and it's just like
a really cool character piece i think
any time we're able to tie
a map and a hero together to kind of
provide more context to our world
it's it's when we're when we're doing
the best version of our world building
and then
pariso also it has a lot of like really
cool moments in it there's high ground
all around the first point and each team
has a different way to access it so
defense can kind of access high ground
from their side of the point and offense
has a few ways of accessing it from
their side and so there's a lot of use
for highly mobile characters on on this
map and then as you move through um and
get towards the end um the the high
ground actually continues um and so
there's uh as you travel through this um
sort of like more quaint village section
of rio there's different rooftops that
you can get to there's different levels
of lucio's club that you can get to
and i think that it's like it's a really
fun
map that really highlights a lot of our
heroes movement abilities
as well as a lot of the um sort of like
long range sight lines that we have
while still providing all these like
tight little flanking routes for heroes
like reaper um and um
i was gonna say junker queen um and
junker queen to excel on
[Music]
there's a lot of new content coming to
overwatch and we're going to be
releasing all of it on a seasonal basis
and our seasons are going to run roughly
nine weeks roughly every other season um
if not a little bit more we'll be adding
a new hero to the game um and on our
other seasons
we're adding things like new maps
new game modes um and as well as events
actually i think events we're hoping to
have
in as many seasons as we possibly can
just because they're like a really fun
moment for players to just kind of
explore different parts of the game
[Music]
i don't want to speak to people
and tell them
how they ought to feel you know or how
they ought to react to to things just in
society in general i can say that um the
overwatch team really loves our game
um and we pour
every day creative energy and passion
into this game
and we just hope that players can see
that when they play it and that it
resonates with them
we always say that
overwatch is a future worth fighting for
or that the world could use more heroes
and
as much as we can we try to
instill those values in our own team
this bright aspirational future
but at the same time i can't say
that
that is everything
that our team culture is it is not
appropriate for me to speak to everybody
else on the team and what their
experience is all i can say is that
as a leader on the team
and as someone that
works with a lot of the other leaders on
our team that
we do try to instill these values across
the team it is something incredibly
important to us um as a development team
to listen to and to create space not
just for our teammates and our
co-workers but for our community
and for our players